oh it's carlson wait carlson is around  my same standing what  did he late join he was playing a  a serious tournament the other day  maybe i'll play carlson hopefully  that would be cool haven't played  carlson in like  close to two years  hey i'm above carlson oh i'm playing  carlson  long time no c let's play a stafford  staff for grandma time ah he declines  da i'm so nervous  oh i'm down the pawn  this is reasonable  i'm really nervous right now actually  i'm surviving kind of  no i got forked he forked me  any hope let's drop the knights  let's go eric i need to like trick  stalemate him  or trick stalemate myself  how to do this no i resigned oh  oh my lifetime score has been ruined  he forced me ah rooksy it was  unfortunate  he also he turned down my stafford i  wanted him to take here but he  he was too afraid i know what to do  oh okay well  he passed me in the tournament too uh  at least where we have an even lifetime  score now